today's video is going to be about my
experiences during undergrad studying
mathematics now I did do a double major
in physics and maths and I've already
made a video called my regret studying
physics so I thought it would only be
fair to make this one to start off I'll
tell you some things that I definitely
don't regret about studying maths number
one would be that I don't regret the
time that I spent studying so I don't
regret the time that I spent studying
and learning mathematical ideas instead
of anything else that I could have been
doing whether it's going out and
partying or doing any other activity I
don't regret that I spent a lot of that
time studying I also don't regret any of
the people that I've met whilst I've
been pursuing maths whether it was like
lecturers or students in my class and my
peers
I've really enjoyed some of the
friendships I've made through math
classes and in fact some of my best
friends have come from there so let's
talk about some of the things that I do
regret and this is actually pretty
nuanced because I would say overall I'm
glad I majored in mathematics I think
it's a good major and I definitely got a
lot out of it this is just inviting over
a captain hindsight to see a few things
that I guess I feel not the greatest
about so the first would be thinking
that I was good at math just because
I've done a course on it or because I
could get a good grade in that course I
also had a lot of confusion between
getting a good grade on something and
that meaning that I actually enjoyed it
what I mean is that I sort of felt like
sometimes more than I enjoyed maths I
just enjoyed the satisfaction of getting
a good grade on something or the feeling
that I could get from doing maths that
had nothing to do with maths at all and
that was more about my personal craving
to do something that satisfied me and to
get you know instant satisfaction in a
way that doing like a maths assignment
especially the low-hanging fruit or the
easy problems in math can give you you
know if you can apply some of these I
you've learned do the homework problem
handed in and get feedback pretty
quickly afterwards it kind of feels good
and it feels like you're accomplishing
something it feels good to just to be
able to finish something that's what I'm
especially talking about these sort of
low hanging fruit problems in math they
really gave me the sense of satisfaction
and I guess I enjoyed that I enjoyed
feeling like I was good at something and
I think it was good for my like self
confidence but I think I confused that
feeling I got from math with actually
enjoying it because sometimes I didn't
enjoy it at all but it was just masked
by this feeling that oh well I got a
good grade so I must be really enjoying
and I must be passionate about this
subject then sometimes I wasn't don't
get me wrong there are some areas of
math I really do enjoy for example I
found my dynamical systems course really
interesting but then there were some
courses that I took I think for other
reasons maybe one of those other reasons
was to like stroke my own ego like I
would take courses that I thought were
notoriously difficult just because I
felt like I should take that challenge
and that people taking those courses
will seem to me the best at math and and
maybe it was the perception that I
wanted other people to believe I was
good at maths as well so I feel like
maybe not all the choices I made in
terms of which classes I picked and
everything like that where I put my
effort was made based on what I actually
enjoyed but it was based on other things
it was based on what I thought I was
good at from these arbitrary grades and
measures and it was based on what I
thought was perceived as like the best
math to be doing or the most prestigious
math to be doing when really none of
those things met it as much so at the
time I wish I guess I'd been a little
bit more aware of what I actually
enjoyed and what I didn't my second
regret is probably thinking that some of
the math was more abstract than it
really was I was presented with a lot of
these really abstract ideas and math and
one thing about them is that they're
very hard I guess to show to people who
are
side of mathematics completely and have
them understand what's going on so it
kind of creates this feeling of like an
elite little Club of people who are in
this math class and they understand
something that kind of very few other
people understand and it's kind of a big
barrier to entry as well sometimes when
it comes to math so there were a lot of
these abstract ideas and I guess I
didn't ever really put much effort into
trying to communicate them to other
people and I would often maybe brush
them off as just being crazily complex
math ideas that you'd never understand
unless you're in this class but it also
affected my own thinking about these
ideas I guess sometimes I felt like
certain exercises and problems that I
was working on only existed in this
strange realm which consisted of the
lecturers in mind my notes and then on
the exam and the problems didn't seem to
exist anywhere outside of this and that
affected the way that I thought about
them I found them not so interesting or
important and I only studied for them in
a way that I was good at answering them
on the exam but didn't have much
knowledge about these problems to apply
outside of that context that lack of
understanding of the bigger picture of
some of these math ideas is one of my
regrets and actually I realized it from
an unlikely source and it was from a
Vsauce video I think the video I
remember it's called like the breakfast
okra and it's actually about finding the
quickest way that you can fall between
two points but the fact is that vsauce
made this really cool video about this
idea and linking it to all these other
physical ideas and it was really cool
video and I was thinking like I have
actually done lots of problems before on
the subject this register crow in math
class and physics class and I never
actually realized it was cool I never
thought about it as being interesting in
this context for other people and I kind
of realized that a lot of the ideas I've
studied were actually interesting
outside
the context of the exam but I've never
been able to see that before I've since
seen a lot of other videos it's someone
like three blue one brown presents math
ideas and I watch them and I think wow
this is actually interesting these ideas
are actually interesting these ideas
that I have learned about a uni but
never cared about I know I wished that
I'd seen a lot of these deeper meanings
at the time and actually used them to be
more engaged with what I was learning
again sure I did appreciate some things
I mean I managed to get through the math
degree so I had some amount of
inspiration behind me and what I'm doing
now on YouTube I think you can see that
I do have a passion for math somewhere
down there but it's definitely been very
small at times and has come and gone but
I really feel like it wasn't until after
I finished a lot of these courses that I
realized these ideas were actually cool
and that I probably should have spent
more time trying to understand how I
could communicate them to other people
because it would have helped me
appreciate that they were cool so those
are my thoughts here it's just based on
my personal experience so let me know if
you can relate to any of these ideas and
as always thanks for watching